flavigny sur ozerain 300 habitants cent
vingt mille touristes chaque année
aujourd'hui complètement vide on dirait
même que ce sont eux immobile qui ont
pris les rênes de la commune
même le maire adjoint semble ne pas
reconnaître flavigny habitude la grange
est ouverte vous avez des parasols nous
avait du monde qui mange dehors des gens
qui font la queue pour aller chercher
leur pain non il a tout est fermé
regardez le silence complet nous
arrivons dans la rue principale
voyez très peu de bruit elle est vide
le magasin labret fermé c'est tout calme
on entend les oiseaux des oiseaux que
peut entendre andré gaillard
il habite ici depuis deux ans depuis sa
fenêtre il voit d'habitude des foules de
touristes se balader prendre des photos
là tout est différent au niveau de
décibels au niveau des rencontres oui
c'est c'est très reposant très reposant
jamais ou la nuit
mais le plein jour comme ça non dans
l'épicerie du village
seuls quelques commandes sont encore
assurée pour les locaux les touristes ne
franchissent plus la porte du magasin
en temps normal ils se pressent pour
acheter des souvenirs au tout tout ce
qui est produits régionaux donc vous
avez balle et zanni
le miel enfin tout ce qui est le vin de
flavigny les crèmes de cassis enfin là
j'ai pas trop fait le double réassort
parce que du coup il n'ya pas j'ai pas
les clients pas non plus l'une des plus
belles communes de france vit donc une
période toute particulière de mémoire de
flavie niant le village médiéval n'avais
jamais connu ça